[Music]
hey
everybody we're back again it's monday
yeah we're here
everybody's talking about what they're
drinking some people like beer and i was
like really
but mango says but it's 8 p.m there yeah
so that's fair
yeah i got drinking iced coffee i got
water i had some iced coffee but i drank
it i got this yesterday it's
one of those little starbucks bottles
and it's like toasted white chocolate
that [ __ ] was freaking delicious okay
those are really good i don't drink them
a lot because they're very high in
calorie but i just
bought that one yesterday when we went
because we had to go get cat treats
we gotta go to walgreens and get cat
treats because pookie was being such a
brat
because remember that show yesterday she
was tearing everything up she's like the
treats are wrong
yeah so she stopped doing that yeah
since i gave her a real treat she's like
okay
okay thank you finally yeah that's just
that's what she was trying to tell us
the whole time
tearing up the whole house because it's
not temptation
i meant to look up yesterday what the
[ __ ] they put in there it's like whoa
i don't understand it yes she was
tearing up our whole house for a day and
a half because we ran out of temptations
and we had to give her the backup treats
yeah it's [ __ ] crazy yeah which that
doesn't she'll eat them but she'll still
she starts turning up that but she'll
like tell you that she's not happy about
it that's not the [ __ ] room but as
soon as we came back yesterday with two
big things of temptation she knew
exactly what that was she was just like
her i showed it to her like that said
look i shook him and she's like
oh oh i walked into the bedroom with him
and she's running because i got a little
bowl here next
in the bedroom she's going she knows new
right where i was going with those
she's like hooray yeah she was so happy
gave her the chicken once and today
she's been real chill
yep she even came in when we were
recording earlier she came in and sat in
town's lap and then she just went and
slept in her bowl
not trying to tear [ __ ] up or anything
yeah she's [ __ ] funny she's really
really smart
all right jenny watched this one called
uh dark and away the dark and the wicked
and i know a couple people had uh
recommended this to me and it's like i
saw that it was for rent on amazon prime
but then i went back and i saw that
shutter was going to
add it uh you know march first or
yesterday or whatever the [ __ ] they
added it i think they had put it up
there thursday or friday so i saw i'm
just gonna wait
and then i'll just watch it on shutter
so that's what i did
uh so i ended up watching this last
night this
was a pretty damn good flip it's creepy
real [ __ ] creepy
i watched it for about 15 minutes and
then when she cut her fingers off on the
on the cutting board
i saw where it was going and i was i'd
seen that gag
about three times the past year or so
and i was like [ __ ] this
i just i thought it was a little too
bland for me
it didn't pull me in early and that i i
have a good
taste i have alright i have a good idea
what it is that my tastes are
if i'm not really pulled into it in the
first five or five or ten minutes i'm
never gonna get pulled into it
and then as it unfolded i was i was
watching it off and on and i was like
yeah
good thing i didn't really watch this
it's just not really my thing
i really really liked it i was i mean
honestly this is one of the ones where
you really kind of have to immerse
yourself like in the
experience of it because a lot of is the
way uh you know the atmosphere the sound
design
um you know the way it's shot and [ __ ]
like that so this was directed by
brian bertino uh probably best known for
doing the strangers back in 2008 also a
really really good flick
this has some similarities with that in
the sense that
it's sort of like a home invasion film
but supernatural rather than
just people you know like invading the
house for me it
for me it felt slow and bland at the
very
you know what i mean in that first 15
minutes so i just i checked out
but i knew jenny was enjoying it it's
her kind of movie she likes that kind of
stuff
well like i said you really had to get
invested in the atmosphere you had to
get invested in the characters there was
a lot
this is one of those movies where
there's a lot going on
under the surface so you really kind of
have to
you have to like pay a lot of attention
to it but one thing that i really really
liked about this one
is that even from the first part of it
and i don't know i feel like it was
maybe the way it was shot too because i
think brian bertino was also
um a producer on uh the black coats
daughter that oz perkins movie
and oz perkins also directed i am the
pretty thing that lives in the house
and this had that same kind of thing
where it's like there were wide shots
and it almost had a thing you know like
in hereditary where
there'd be stuff and then like you were
always constantly like looking in the
corners and in the shadows because you
felt like there was like [ __ ] in there
it had that kind of thing like it had
these really cool
like wide shots these really kind of
disturbing
so you always felt like there was
something that was like this kind of
palpable sense of dread was like there
was something like back there all the
time
so i think that was really well conveyed
by
the way it was shot and just this kind
of like bleak atmosphere
so the story of it is that there's this
really really remote farmhouse in texas
and there's a woman who lives there with
her husband and he's dying
and he so he's kind of you know
bedridden with the oxygen on and
everything like that
and at the beginning you can tell that
there's something
and you assume that it's supernatural
because you can't really see it like all
they have all these goats like they have
all this herd of goats and the goats are
getting all upset
and um you know there's kind of bottles
and they're kind of shaking and you
can't really see what's in there
and there's like all these like weird
creeping creaking noises so like i said
the sound design in this is really good
there's like all these really kind of
like unsettling kind of noises like
happening sort of behind you and [ __ ]
and um so the mom is like freaking out
now the two grown
kids whose names are louise and michael
they come out there because i guess the
dad is dying and they want to help her
out and like say goodbye to dad and
everything even though the mom has
specifically told them not to come out
there
although she won't tell them why now the
interesting thing about this
family is that you can tell they never
communicate about anything they never
talk to each other about anything
they're very like disconnected from one
another
and i guess this is what makes them
weak and what makes this entity which
they never really say it's good demonic
or it could be the devil could be
something like that
but it kind of like um
you know that's what allows the devil to
kind of come in there and start [ __ ]
with them
because there's kind of no because
they're so disconnected as a family so i
think there was like a really really
good
um i mean that was really really well
done this kind of sense of isolation
disconnection
you know these people are a family but
they don't really feel
anything for one another um so i think
that was like really well conveyed like
i said there's like i don't want to
spoil too much about it because this is
pretty new this is 20 from 2020.
but it's definitely a slow burn like i
said not really uh
wouldn't be tom's cup of tea but if you
liked
um if you like the strangers you'll
probably like this because it's the same
director thank you
um you have to read it it says saw your
true detective video and the reason i'm
so excited for the new bond film is
because the director of that show
is doing no time to die so there you go
no time to die it's gonna bomb dude just
telling you
they've been well that that doesn't mean
it's going to be a bad movie though
no time to die no it's going to be bad
you keep reshooting it that's the spirit
they keep reshooting it over and over
and over again and they don't want to
show it and then they just
that that that shit's gonna that's gonna
bomb uh i mean
if that [ __ ] what funny about no time to
die is that it
has a good cast it's just that the buzz
around that movie is bad
you know they just
no i'm just gonna say no that that's not
gonna work we're gonna see
if if they reshoot the movie to fix it
maybe but there's just i've been keeping
up with
that movie for the past [ __ ] year and
and no
no they're gonna try to sabotage that
[ __ ] that whole
um property basically okay go ahead jim
um yeah so what was i saying uh i don't
really remember but um if
but if you um if you like the strangers
although this is
like i said this is more supernatural
demonic type of thing
if you liked oz perkins movies which uh
at least one of which brian bertino uh
produced as well if you like that kind
of slow burn atmospheric even if you
feel like hereditary this
did kind of remind me a little bit of
hereditary just in parts of it were like
i said this kind of like
you know impending dread this kind of
like broken family
and something invading them and like
preying on their weakness in that way
um had slight slight bit of the shining
too like especially the way it kind of
went from day to day like with the card
like saying what day it was
and how everything just kind of like
ramped up and up and there was like some
really really good
really creepy kind of hereditary-esque
um imagery in it like especially the one
like when the brother looks out the
window and sees a particular thing
um xander berkeley is in this too
playing a priest he's uh
was on uh the walking dead for a while
he was the dude that was like the
the head of that one i haven't watched
the walking dead in so long that i can't
remember that one that one place where
maggie was
running the [ __ ] that one that one
[ __ ] yeah
that was kind of like the mayor that
lived in the big mansion or whatever
i can't remember what his character name
was because like i said it's been a
couple years because i've missed the
last
season or last season or whatever but um
you know
but yeah so this it just came out on
shutter like i said i think you can rent
it probably on amazon prime and other
places
but if you're into real slow burn horror
and if you like i said this is one of
the ones where
you really have to kind of give this
your entire attention gave me a little
bit of
the lodge vibe too it's a little bit
like the lodge
so if you like that kind of [ __ ] then
you will probably love this i thought
it's like some of the imagery in it i
thought was like super super creepy i
really really liked
the atmosphere of it i really liked
those wide shots and like it
made you nervous like because you
weren't really sure what the [ __ ] was
going on in the background because it
like
always looked like [ __ ] was going on in
the background and i found out later on
that just like in hereditary sometimes
there was some [ __ ] in the shot
but you couldn't exactly see it but your
brain kind of picked up on it a little
bit
so i think that's you know that was
really effective and like giving you
that sort of feeling
but yeah it's like i really really liked
it i thought it was super creepy and
it's like like i said it
kind of starts out kind of slow but
i noticed that as i was watching it i
kept like leaning like
closer and closer like toward to the
screen because i was just kind of
getting
like hypnotically like sucked into it i
guess as it was going on
but uh yeah i thought it was right i
thought it was pretty damn good i
thought it was pretty creepy
you know yeah yeah i didn't like it i
thought it lacked
taste it not taste it lacks the texture
it was kind of
gray and dull and it's slow
um i could see if you liked hereditary
with even though a lot of people liked
hereditary
it had that kind of a tone yeah it's
very bleak
yeah but nihilistic almost i would call
it i don't want to spoil the ending but
it is pretty like nylon but for me
hereditary
was a little more interesting in the
beginning i still fell asleep
in hereditary remember that when that
girl's [ __ ] head got whacked off
[ __ ] i laughed my ass off
and then i fell asleep in the damn and
everybody looked at me like i was an
[ __ ]
i just suck you are an awesome yeah i
liked this summer
yes and i just didn't like hereditary
from what i remember of it um i didn't
really like this one i didn't think
there was really anything to it it
didn't get my intention
early on yeah if you don't get my
attention in the first five minutes
you're never going to get my attention
yes well like i said that's just what it
is a lot of times
with movies you know i guess which is
why i'm wearing more in horror movies
and books and stuff like that than you
are
is that you really have to
i mean you have to commit to it if
you're gonna watch it [ __ ]
yeah no i mean if you're gonna watch it
it's like pay attention to it and like
pay attention to what's going on
pay attention because everything's done
for a reason
so i mean you have to kind of be willing
to
yeah i just have a hard time paying
attention to things that aren't exciting
or
aren't very yeah you know i mean and
it's i
i go there for a show and this show's
gotta be kind of like a visual
experience
i like [ __ ] like real good color
palettes good music good score behind it
it's gotta be enjoyable to watch i don't
like i don't like things hey now
you guys know what i'm talking about i
don't like things that are
tedious to watch and for me this is this
is tedious
uh but it is this is the kind of [ __ ]
that jenny likes not saying it's bad
yeah it's just not to my taste yeah i
didn't find it tedious because like i
said i got kind of sucked into the story
and like sucked into the relationships
and
you know what the [ __ ] was gonna happen
because i wasn't entirely clear what was
gonna happen
or what was going on and i think that
was like really good and like i said the
way it was shot was like really good
are we talking bleak in the style of the
witch kind of like that
it does kind of remind me it's very a24
it just really kind of gave me that vibe
just very bleak very isolating very
dread inducing there's always like
there's like it feels like there's
something bad hanging over you like the
whole time that you watch it so it gave
me that kind of vibe
um you know obviously i didn't like it
as much as hereditary because i think
that's probably like my favorite
movie from the past you know 10 20 years
but
um it was along those same lines uh
seth says i'm looking forward to seeing
the new coming to america i really hope
sexual chocolate makes an appearance
yeah
i said the exact same thing i said they
gotta put sexual chocolate in it and
they gotta put soul glow in there soul
glow's gotta be in there so glow has to
have evolved into something over the
years
yeah i want to see some infomercials for
soul glow in the new coming to america
well i mean we'll definitely review that
like when it comes out
because we just watched the first one
like we just re-watched the first one
the other night
yeah zach the reason why preparation the
reason why i think no time to die
is going to suck is just because of the
pro the statements that
um people that have worked on it what
they
said in the press i guess trying to
jumble up or trying to what do they call
it they're trying to
gin up support for the movie and as soon
as they
started to gin up the idea that it was
the james bond for the new era of people
who now understand that james bond is a
pig and that he has to go
this is the james bond for people that
have always hated james bond so if
you're a james bond fan
you're gonna [ __ ] hate this because
they've got him in there
he's in there to show what an outmoded
and outdated
uh male chauvinist pig stereotype that
is
that's that's the the um which
stupid that's the beck and bad way to go
the james bond [ __ ] theme the whole
spin of james bond it was retro even
back before retro it was always retro
that's the way that character was it's
like saying you know what
in the past superman was weak but today
it's in the past superman was strong
but today's superman should be weak
let's make superman weak
well that's not superman although the
thing about it is that
i mean i can see the old james bonds
like people saying about that but the
daniel craig ones never struck me as
having that
so yeah yeah by today's standards it
still is
yeah they just came right out and said
what they were going to do with it
so no i'm not going to see that i'm
going to support that
i'm not going to give money to that and
what's the name broccoli who owns that
[ __ ] brand
that's just they just they [ __ ]
themselves because
they're gonna the entire fan base is
gonna walk away from it people that
don't give a [ __ ] about [ __ ] james
bond aren't gonna go see james bond
because it's now anti-sexist or whatever
you're not gonna you're not gonna swing
them
it's always gonna be the same fans so
that movie's gonna bomb
and they keep reshooting it because it
sucks
they keep showing it to test audiences
and the [ __ ]
fans go man [ __ ] that you know [ __ ] that
james bond
and then the people who are indifferent
are like no [ __ ] that james bond too
so you're not gonna make these people
happy it should go back to
the way it was you know for the other
daniel craig
movies they were good but this was
eventually they might beat it into the
shape
of the prior uh daniel craig
movies but it will be an inferior
product probably
it's a shame because they got some good
villains in there and they got
some good you know like that what's the
name the dude from [ __ ] mcqueen
behind me rhapsody was that guy's name
robin molly yeah he's he's one of the
villains in it
and it looked really [ __ ] cool but
the messaging of the movie
it's already ruined most of the people
that are watching it
watching the development of the movie
who were the fans of the old
daniel craig series are already saying
[ __ ] it i'm not seeing that
so they're stupid you know
hollywood's stupid and even though
that's not even hollywood i don't really
care
it's not gonna get asses into seats like
i said i'll probably end up seeing it
and it's just kind of like
free maybe i'm not like i said i'm not
i've i haven't
pinned a lot of i i don't think about it
one way or the other
yeah let's be honest with you well
you're not a fan
i really liked the daniel craig once
yeah so did i but you know i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna cry if like the new one is
not good they're gonna make it [ __ ]
shitty they're gonna make it shitty i'm
not worried about it's gonna be like
it's gonna be just like
um uh what was that [ __ ] not force
awake it's last jedi it's gonna be like
a last jedi
i walked out of last jedi going mad [ __ ]
this that was that was the end of star
wars for me
mandalorian came back but they [ __ ]
mandalorian up
there won't be another mandalorian i
don't believe that the
the um that [ __ ] so [ __ ] you know
everybody's talking about what happened
with mandalorian
and the guy who's [ __ ] what's his
five row they're trying to get rid of
his ass yeah
he's gonna because [ __ ] the other
faction that controls disney
[ __ ] over every [ __ ] planned series
he had
now they're trying to get rid of [ __ ]
the girl that played ahsoka
what's her name ahsoka they're trying to
get her [ __ ] bad
because kennedy's gonna try to get rid
of everything favro does because she
wants
control of over that license over that
brand
but she can't do it high republic
[ __ ] sucks
she can't do it
so [ __ ] disney
i'm not happy now disney i guess will
anything that's cool they're gonna [ __ ]
it over
yeah that's what they're gonna do okay
well uh i guess i'll find a new movie to
watch tonight that i'm sure tom will
hate as well
yeah and then we will talk about it and
then we'll talk about it tomorrow
we'll have a match i didn't hate this
movie it just wasn't it was just what i
just wasn't that interested in it okay
well i'll find one tonight to watch them
maybe you'll like better or you can pick
how about that
you can pick you can pick
i don't know i was thinking today that
maybe after the end of this month or
after i get the cookbook done
i was thinking of maybe um
discontinuing the witching hour series
because i like doing that but it doesn't
get a lot of hits and it's
kind of time consuming and then i
thought maybe i could use the time
and do more movie reviews or book
reviews
because i was looking the other day i
was like god man there's so many [ __ ]
horror movies that i really need to get
to old ones new ones everything i have
this huge list and it's like i really
need to start working my way through
that and especially like for the movie
retrospective which we only get to do
once a week
then the matinees which we only do like
three of those a week so i don't get to
see a lot of
stuff for it so i don't know i'm
thinking about it i'll just i'll wait
until maybe the end of the month and
then i'll decide what to do with it
um so maybe maybe i'll be doing more
movie reviews and maybe more book
reviews although these took a long time
because i got to read the whole book but
you know
i don't know it's just something let's
just thought i was throwing around but
yeah so uh
i'll see you guys again tomorrow uh put
that on a shirt jenny watch heat okay
[Laughter]
all right so we'll see you guys oh no oh
we haven't finished heat remember that's
what you stand right yeah yeah well i
i gotta see it um yeah